من جهتها اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه مقتل
63 جنديا من قواتها نتيجه قصف اوكرانيا
صاروخي في منطقه
بمقاطعه دونياسك وقالت الوزاره ان القصف
تم بسته صواريخ من طراز هاي مارس
الامريكيه الصنع
تطورات الميدانيه اخرى شهدتها مناطق
الشرقيه اوكرانيا حيث اعلنت السلطات
المواليه لروسيا في مقاطعه لوغانس انا
كبدت القوات الاكرانيه خسائر كبيره وقضت
على نحو سبعين عسكريا اوكرانيا خلال
الساعات الماضيه بينما تستمر القوات
الاوكرانيه في استهداف الاحياء السكنيه
وفي دنياك افاده مراسل الجزيره بوقوع
انفجار كبيرا هز مدينه درش كيف نتيجه
سقوطه صاروخ على منطقه قريبه من محطه
القطارات في المدينه تسبب باضرار كبيره في
المنازل المحيطه جنوبا في ذا برج افادت
السلطات الاخرانيه بتجدد القصص الروسي على
البنيه التحتيه المدنيه في ثمانيه عشره
مقاطعه وقريه اما في نيكولايز فذكرت
الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه ان القوات
الروسيه تواصل قصف المناطق الساحليه في
المقاطعه وان القصفه طال تجمعات مائيه في
منطقه اوتشاكوف وبشبه جزيره القرم قال
عمده مدينه سبانستوبول الموالي لروسيا ان
المضادات الجويه الروسيه اسقطت ثلاثه
طائرات مسيره اوكرانيه فوق البحر الاسود
قباله المدينه